When you get tumors removed and they give you all that data about them,
is there any of it important to know for treatment moving forward?
Yes, of course there is.
So they should do what's called a pathology report on that biopsy.
So if they removed the tumor or they did a biopsy of a tumor,
they're doing a pathology report to see what that cell type of that tumor is.
If it is cancer, so you can have a tumor removed and it's benign, it's not cancerous,
that you're going to get that report, it's not cancerous, and that was the pathology report.
If you get a tumor removed and it was cancerous, then they will be testing for what type of cancer it is.
More than likely it's going to be a metastasis of the primary cancer.
We have people maybe on this call today that have several different primary cancers.
That's fairly rare, but it is possible person can have liver cancer and breast cancer.
So that's why if they do a biopsy of let's say deliver and of a person who has no breast cancer,
you don't just assume that it's breast cancer metastasized to the liver.
It could be liver cancer.
First of all, they have to find out if it's cancer and they'll see what cell type it is.
And let's say if it's breast cancer, then it's breast cancer metastasized to the liver.
So would there be change a change in the right program?
Probably not, would there be a change in maybe supplement?
Maybe so it's good to get a cheek swab test done.
And if it is pathology, then yes, you need to know what cell type it is.
Also, if they do a horrible sensitivity test on it, which usually takes another week or so,
you could have a primary tumor, let's say you had a primary breast tumor,
let's say it's triple negative.
It's ER negative and PR negative.
And then it metastasized to the lungs, let's say you do a biopsy of that.
And that's estrogen positive.
Why is that?
Well, because cancer can change.
And that is not that uncommon actually.
So it's still breast cancer.
It's still metastasized from the original primary tumor site.
But it's how it's responding to hormones is differently.
So estrogens are blocking the eight-all receptor on that in that scenario.
So yes, they will do a pathology.
So that can just remove a tumor or not test for it.
So yes, they'll do a path report on any tumor that is removed.
Any other questions?
Nobody went over that information with me from my surgery last September.
So I didn't know if I miss any information.
So I had to go back through the chronology.
You'd have to look into the chronology of your care.
And see what they say about that.
We should be in the notes, the pathology report.
Should be in your notes somewhere.
So I would look for that if I were you.
If you do have a my chart system, it would be that typically be fun to that for pathology record post surgically report.
Typically the post surgically report is going to tell is going to explain the surgery itself.
We did this and this and this procedure took this size out.
And then the pathology report would follow that.
And that would be sent out of the layouts.